bonsoir et bienvenue dans votre émission
culturelle kiosque c'est reparti pour
une nouvelle saison au sommaire ce soir
vers les yvelines tout un programme de
balades à pied à vélo ou à cheval c'est
du 13 au 28 septembre dans l'ensemble du
département mais nous en parlons dans
quelques instants avec notre invité les
jean-christophe bardot et photographe il
raconte en cinq à sept clichés l'avis de
certains verts lee roy une exposition se
tient sur le parvis du scarabée à la
chronique de nicolas gerber se rince
consacré à l'exposition hommage à
bernard d'orival prochainement à magny
les hameaux et puis aussi la chronique
cinéma avec vos habits de spectateurs et
le coup de coeur d'un professionnel ce
soir luc beaucamp dû signer cette
d'elancourt mais tout de suite on va
parler balade
on va parler de verre les yvelines c'est
du 13 au 28 septembre ce sont une
quarantaine de ballades qui sont
proposés dans le département des balades
à pied à vélo ou à cheval et pour en
parler avec moi ce soir patrick aux âmes
bonsoir alors vers les yvelines c'est la
deuxième édition rappelez-nous un peu la
philosophie et principes de berlin c'est
effectivement la deuxième édition qui
évolue et un petit peu notamment ce
concerne la date
c'était au printemps et au printemps
1320 automne magnifique c'est comme un
printemps c'est clair et ça incite tout
à fait à la randonnée alors l'idée c'est
elle est doublée d'une part de donner
l'occasion aux yvelinois et à d'autres
participants notamment les parisiens qui
sont dans notre préoccupation leur faire
goûter le plaisir des yvelines qui est
très proche de chez eux donc leur donner
l'occasion de d'avoir des activités
sportives légères familiale et d'autre
part le deuxième but c'est de donner
l'occasion à des gens qui connaissent ou
qui ne connaissent pas de découvrir
toutes les richesses du département des
yvelines qui est un département
absolument formidable sur le plan des
espaces verts sur le plan du patrimoine
culturel sur le plan de de toutes les
activités qu'on peut avoir sans cesse de
dire qu'effectivement vous l'avez dit si
c'est vraiment un public familial plutôt
conserver et c'est aussi une façon de
découvrir le patrimoine du mans et en
particulier la scène qui est quand même
un axe majeur de pour les yvelines et
donc on est absolument convaincu que la
scène à potentiel touristique en tant
que tel et je préciserai rapidement que
les impressionnistes sont venus à chatou
puisque c'est là que ça a démarré et que
l'aventuré a démarré sont venus à chatou
à cause de la lumière et à cause de la
scène parce qu'il y avait les balades
sur la seine en bateau en panne
effectivement de neufchâteau jusqu'à
quoi si c'est absolument sa jeune
carrière jusqu'au pic mais ouais tout à
fait jusqu'au paix que si ce schéma des
impressionnistes qui est très jolie
jeudi une activité vraiment familial il
ya on n'est pas chronométré c'est une
invitée à venir se servir en données où
chacun participe avec sa capacité
physique que ce soit à pied à cheval
pour le cheval il est demandé d'avoir un
certain niveau gratereau capm enfin
c'est quelque chose d'absolument cours
en ce qui concerne le vélo en tout cas
il n'y a pas de chronométrage n'y a pas
de filtre quelconque c'est une activité
familiale et on s'inscrit bien dans ce
que veut faire le département qui est
des activités qui sont ces activités
douces d'où le partenariat que nous
permet de mentionner avec la sncf car
notre idée c'est que tous les gens qui
vivent tous les habitants de l'île de
france doivent pouvoir prendre le train
le rer avec leur vélo pour venir ça
c'est un premier partenariat c'est la
première c'est la première année qui a
partenariats de ce type là mais je suis
convaincu le succès vu la manière dont
la sncf a répondu très très largement je
suis justement patrick auzanneau puisque
vous en parlez comment la sncf a répondu
à l'appel de verre les idées on va
écouter bernard gosselin il est
directeur sncf paris rive gauche et on
la rencontrait hier soir au château de
rambouillet à l'occasion de la soirée de
lancement de l'opération
ce partenariat vers des yvelines fait
partie d'un partenariat plus large que
nous avons depuis deux ans avec le
conseil général des yvelines pour mener
des opérations
de promotion des départements de d
des possibilités qui a dans le
département pour ce pour ce véhicule et
nous avons des dans ce partenariat
d'autres actions de type plus sociétale
et puis nous avons un volet touristique
déjà va y avoir des affiches à voir des
affiches dans les gares à la fois dans
les gares de paris et dans les gares des
yvelines pour faire la promotion de ce
partenariat et notamment des randonnées
que l'on peut faire au départ des gares
on va demander aux cheminots aux agents
de la sncf d'en faire la promotion les
cheminots vont faire la promotion de
verre les yvelines je rappelle aussi que
c'est important de le dire c'est que les
animations sont gratuites en jambes des
randonnées sont gratuites les animations
sont gratuites on demande à tous les
participants de s'inscrire pour des
raisons de l'assurance grosso modo la
seule chose qui soit payante
éventuellement c'est quand il ya un
repas d'organiser sur place mais ce sont
des sommes très modeste de l'ordre de 10
euros c'est vrai pour les randonnées à
cheval c'est vrai également pour une des
randonnées vélo celle qui est longue qui
fait le 50 km puisqu'il y a au milieu
des animations et un repas qui sont
proposés donc d'ensemble et gratuit vers
la saisine du 13 au 28 septembre via le
site internet qui s'affiche pour avoir
toutes les dates de randonnée il ya
quand même trois moments forts qui sont
organisés chaque dimanche est ce que
vous nous parler de ces moments on va
commencer peut-être par la première par
part dimanche prochain dans l'eau n'est
effectivement il faut aller voir sur le
site toutes les randonnées qui lie à
puisqu'il ya quarante allemand car hors
de lui et donc il faut que chacun
repères ce qui peut l'intéresser
l'implantation géographique puisque de
ça couvre une grande partie du
département mais il y a trois grands
temps forts qui sont les dimanches
puisque évidemment les participants
devraient en principe être beaucoup plus
nombreux c'est pour ces grandes
manifestations qui sur lequel on a mis
un petit peu d'emphase dimanche prochain
le 14 il y à la randonnée médiéval dans
le pays de houdan ou là il y à la fois
randonnée à pied et puis une animation
avec des comédiens qui remettent en
scène ce qu est l époque médiévale et
donc c'est à la fois quelque chose
de promenades et de randonnées en plein
air mais en même temps très très
culturel donc ça tout à fait sa place
dans vos kiosques parce que il ya
vraiment une évocation de l'époque
médiévale c'est donc à houdan dimanche
prochain il ya eu 21 il a ordonné à ses
fans je battais là il y à la randonnée à
cheval là aussi il y a donc le souhait
de que les gens participent à ce du
cheval mais également le souhait de
découvrir des lieux le château de
breteuil que beaucoup connaissent mais
pas tout le monde il y a également le
château de dampierre qui fait partie du
programme et et en même temps des
balades en plein air qui sont très la
dernière randolac
rondo mais il ya bien la rando qui se
passe au lycée c'est cher à votre coeur
puisque je représente le pays des
impressionnistes qui est toute la boucle
de la seine entre croissy sur seine et
le pecq etc et donc on a la
particularité d'être comme je mentionné
précédemment au bord de la seine et
notre randonnée va être faire un grand
parcours le long de la seine avant de
revenir en arrière la grande boucle fait
52 km pour ceux qui veulent devenir
toute la journée 32 pour ceux qui ne
viendrait que l'après midi donc bords de
seine on remonte par la forêt de saint
germain le château saint germain la
forêt de marly et l'abitibi gens qui
veulent pas mettre un peu sportif un
patrick voisin de je vous le dirai à
l'armée
d'être ce qu'on nous présentait cette
opération aérienne des yvelines et et
puis avant de de continuer parmi les
opérations proposées y en a une
quarantaine il ya trois balades qui ont
lieu sur notre territoire saint
quentinois durant ce week-end la
première concerne samedi une balade si
qui se proposait avec l'office de
tourisme de la balade part de la gare de
saint quentin en yvelines elles durent
15 km une balade à pied cette fois
proposer toujours samedi depuis l'entrée
de la base de loisirs de saint quentin
et vous pourrez suivre la balade grâce à
des bornes marquée de fleurs de lys
balade royal donc et puis dimanche
toujours à la base de loisirs de saint
quentin mais c'est du côté du centre
équestre qu'il faudra aller puisque le
centre propose une randonnée à cheval en
cas d' encadrer je précise que la
randonnée peut être pratiqué par des
débutants voilà ce qu'on pouvait lire
pour vers les yvelines on quitte lui ni
r des balades pour celui de la
photographie
jean-christophe bardot a photographié
des verriers roi ou des personnes
impliquées dans cette commune il a
également fait participer des
photographes amateurs son travail n'est
pas encore terminé mais il montre ses
premiers travaux dans une exposition en
plein air actuellement sur le parvis du
scarabée
des portraits qui s'affiche en plein
coeur de la ville de leur ville ils sont
installés ou impliqués à la verrière ces
femmes ces hommes jeunes ou moins jeunes
se sont prêtés au jeu de l'objectif de
jean christophe bardot en quelques
photos ils racontent leur vie dans la
ville je vais les voir une première fois
je leur explique un petit peu le projet
le dispositif un portrait en cinq six
sept images c'est pas juste votre visage
qui m'intéresse c'est
comment on voit la ville de chez vous
objet image une image de famille quelque
chose qui dit d'où vous venez je vais
les voir sur le lieu de travail je vais
les voir sur leurs lieux d'activités
associatives je l'essaie de les
retrouver aussi au milieu des autres ce
qui laissait pas d'isoler le portrait
c'est de replacer la personne dans un
dans un contexte
à la fois faut que les images elles elle
parle des gens elle a un sens par
rapport à ce qui nous raconte tout ce
qui me propose quand je leur demande un
lieu qui compte pour eux dans la ville
parfois il ya plusieurs propositions
donc je fais des essais mois ensuite je
vais voir les bas je fais et puis il ya
des choses qui
doit leur corresponde mais il ya des
choses qui me touchent plus
photographiquement
jean-christophe bardot a également fait
appel à d'autres photographes amateurs
lors d'un atelier qui a duré six mois
très peu de textes pour accompagner les
photos les images parlent d'elles mêmes
mamadou diawara cet ancien ouvrier de
renault incontournable dans sa ville est
aujourd'hui maire de son village au mali
jean-christophe nous décrit son portrait
en cette photo qu'elle a vue de la
fenêtre il ya le portrait n'est
évidemment le visage qui en général
n'est pas la première image que je fais
j'attends d'avoir rencontré les gens
plusieurs fois avant de les
photographier parce que c'est pareil un
visa vaudois on doit s'y habituer voir
comment bush comment il réagit je
demande à chacun une photo de famille
c'est très ouvert la photo de famille
c'est une photo qui parle de des gens un
autre moment qu'aujourd'hui
l'objet c'est l'objet qui compte pour
lui c'est que je demande aussi à tout le
monde c'est son écharpe et son insigne
d'élus maliens j'ai eu la chance de
pouvoir l'accompagner à diaby gay
plusieurs fois dans le passé du temps
avec pays et donc donc il me semblait
plus intéressant de le remettre dans
en lien avec ce qu'il a fait au mali je
les regardais pendant qu'il regardait
son portrait est bon il a dit c'est bien
assez bien comment il m'a dit ah tu vas
pas louper
les photographies sont exposées jusqu'au
16 septembre sur le parvis du scarabée
elles rejoindront ensuite la maison de
quartier orly-parc mais le travail n'est
pas fini il reste encore à
jean-christophe bardot une dizaine de
portraits réalisés
l'univers à d'hervé di rosa entre à la
maison elsa triolet aragon à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines pionnier de
l'art modeste hervé di rosa y présente
ses oeuvres numériques et sculptures
issues des cultures populaires oreilles
à domicile et le des moines
c'est dans le sud des divines que font
escale nigaud et votre rené les
personnages récurrents de l'artiste
hervé di rosa
jusqu'au 25 novembre la maison elsa
triolet aragon un lieu de patrimoine
ouvert création contemporaine propose de
découvrir un autre aspect du travail de
l'artiste la peinture numérique des
oeuvres réalisées à partir d'un nate
heures puis imprimé l'exposition sur des
toiles c'est une facette nouvelle je
tairai de son travail puisqu'il a
commencé les oeuvres numériques en 2010
et là vraiment il utilise l'ordinateur
comme on utilise un pinceau une palette
et ils crèvent vraiment de façon
informatique toutes les oeuvres et après
on projette où on imprime voilà on donne
une vie à l'oeuvre donc là ce sont des
toiles mais ça pourrait être des
projections puisque ce sont des oeuvres
finalement l'immatériel des oeuvres
colorées et graphique inspiré de la
bande dessinée dans lesquels on retrouve
le peuple des rené figure emblématique
du monde d'hervé di rosa il n'avait pas
utilisé les relais depuis des années
puisqu'elle réapparaissent l'a récemment
dans son oeuvre est en fait c'est
l'homme de tous les jours
qui est dans des situations du quotidien
mais toujours de façon loufoque coloré
et vraiment tout le monde se retrouve en
fait dans ces personnages là il ya eu
neuf que je trouve très intéressante ces
guerres n'a recours parce que là on voit
à la fois
comment ils utilisent une histoire de
l'art avec ce clin d'oeil à guernica
d'application est à la fois ce côté
bande dessinée que l'on trouve dans
l'oeuvre pour va retrouver dans des
images contemporaines une démarche
artistique qui s'inscrit dans le
prolongement de la figuration libre
l'art modeste comme le qualifie hervé di
rosa un art qui dépasse les frontières
de genre sans hiérarchie de valeurs
entre haute et basse culture
l'exposition de peintures numériques et
de sculptures qui a déjà accueilli plus
de 6000 visiteurs depuis le 17 mai est
prolongé jusqu'au 25 novembre
puis à noter aussi dans vos agendas
l'association art convergence qui
propose une exposition workshop portrait
des dessins des peintures des
photographies réalisées et c'est la
particularité par des artistes souffrent
de troubles psychiques à découvrir à
partir du 18 septembre au domaine de
madame elisabeth à versailles
comme tous les mercredis la chronique de
nicolas gervais et ce soir nicolas nous
présente l'exposition hommage à bernard
d'orival 7 à magny les hameaux
nicolas de staël sonia delaunay zaourou
qui soulage ou encore monnaie ce sont
des tableaux exceptionnels que nous
présente le musée national de port royal
des champs du 18 septembre 19 décembre à
l'occasion d'un hommage à son fondateur
bernard d'orival pour nous en parler le
conservateur du musée philippe lui et
c'est un hommage à bernard d'orival
bernardo rival est peu connu du grand
public mais bernard d'orival est
important pour nous car c'est lui qui en
1953 a été chargé par le ministre chargé
des affaires culturelles donc pas encore
remis de la culture de créer le musée de
port royal des champs bernardo rival
c'est un d'abord ce normalien c'est un
littéraire qui rentrent très tôt dès
1941 comme conservateur du futur musée
d'art moderne c'est-à-dire l'ancêtre du
musée beaubourg est spécialisé dans
l'art du xxème et en même temps c'est un
littéraire qui s'intéressent à racines
et qui écrit pendant la guerre tout un
livre sur ce que port royal a apporté à
racine dans les grande pièce écrite par
le dramaturge
c'est ce titre qui lui permet d'abord
d'organiser une exposition philippe de
champaigne à l'orangerie de paris puis
d'être chargé de la création du musée de
port royal des champs mais il reste en
même temps conservateur du musée d'art
moderne et professionnellement son
activité porte
plutôt sur l'art du 20e sur la création
du musée
d'art contemporain avec des contacts
avec des artistes bernardo rival
à côté de son activité de conservateurs
fréquentent les artistes et réunit une
collection tout à fait impressionnante
on arrive à ça la fin de sa vie à la
constitution d'une collection
impressionnante de plus de 200 oeuvres
qui vont du xvème siècle de là tout
début de la renaissance italienne
jusqu'aux artistes les plus
contemporains le tableau le plus ancien
que l'exposition présente est un tableau
peint par un suiveur de botticelli et la
fin du xvème siècle et dans l'exposition
on trouve aussi des oeuvres exécutées
par pierre soulages qui est encore en
vie ou par jean cortot qui est lui-même
encore en vie donc on est sur un
magnifique panorama de l'art du 15e
siècle à aujourd'hui
l'exposition présente un choix de
cinquante oeuvres pour les périodes on
va dire ancien c'est à dire avant la
guerre de 14 ce sont des oeuvres
on a par exemple un très joli pastel de
monnaie dans la série des vues de
londres exécutés dans les années 1880
par exemple comme on peut avoir un très
joli jacques villon qui représente deux
fillettes exécuté vers 1907
la partie art du 20e est un petit peu le
reflet de la vie artistique à paris dans
les années 50 et 60 de ces artistes
qu'on a pu appeler les artistes de la
nouvelle école de paris et qui sont très
représentés précisément dans les
premières collections rassemblées pour
la création du musée d'art moderne ces
artistes s'est magnifié ses bases n
c'est faisant figure un peu denses être
au georges rouault
l'exposition et la collection de dorival
permet de mesurer combien
l'art de cette immédiate après guerre et
des années 60 est un art variés
foisonnant extrêmement multiples
explorant un petit peu toutes les
solutions proposées au début du 20e
siècle pour d'orival et c'est sans doute
une leçon forte de cette exposition il
n'y a pas de séparation entre art
classique autres guinée et art moderne
noir contemporain bernardo rival à la
même approche qu'il parle d'un tableau
exécuté par philippe de champaigne ou
qu'ils parlent d'un tableau exécuté par
pierre soulages
un instantané de ce qu'a pu être le
musée d'art moderne précisément au
moment où ils ouvrent sur le plateau de
beaubourg
merci nicolas
une date à retenir encore avant de
repeindre le salon alex lutz sera en
spectacle humoristique bien sûr le 9
octobre au prisme à bientôt
trois dates à retenir cette fois dans
l'agenda musique c'est ce dimanche à 11h
à la maison jean monnet de bazoches sur
guyonne un concert lecture autour d'un
texte de romain rolland un texte
d'actualité en ces pages de
commémoration du centenaire de la grande
guerre puisqu'il s'agit d'un manifeste
publié en septembre 1914 pour dénoncer
le sacrifice des soldats manifeste donc
mis en musique ils sont de guyancourt et
ont participé à la réalisation d'un clip
musical un travail mené 2 lors de stages
proposés par le service jeunesse de la
ville est encadré par une équipe de
professionnels en deux semaines ils ont
écrit enregistré tournée le résultat un
clip intitulé un jour j'y arriverai
tourné à guillon courait à montigny le
clip est visible sur le site internet de
la ville je vous en propose un extrait
discret est à noter 1 et par échange les
murs
j'ai besoin de personne non personne moi
j'avance et me faire tout seul r2 2
mais l'inquiétude matin dit
allô maman le papa fiston a dit cet
album vous raconter mon histoire le
temps se fige gtrra pékin fait des
erreurs je m'en excuse auprès de mes
proches de mes prédécesseurs
allez comme toutes les semaines on
retrouve la chronique cinéphiles nous
démarrons avec les sorties à signer vos
avis éclairés de spectateurs au micro d'
elodie moines c'est très bien et mon
enfant m'a bien plu c'est un bon
intégration ces adaptations sorte le
film ndione bon avec les durées de trois
heures c'est long mais c'est vrai que
c'est comme ça le fait moins bien voilà
et
j'ai beaucoup aimé c'est un très beau
film et on a vraiment l'impression de
sentir les odeurs et saveurs de la
cuisine vous pouvez laisser une bonne
comédie romantique bien sympathique et
un tout petit peu longuette voilà c'est
un joli film j'ai bien aimé qu'une fan
de fabrice luchini alors voilà très bien
les acteurs sont très bien c'est très
bien interprété j'aime beaucoup
fabrice luchini donc il est toujours
très
très professionnel c'est un très bon
film très bon film très bons moments
passés que je vais recommander toute
façon
et on passe maintenant au coup de coeur
d'un professeur du septième art ce soir
luc beaucamp dû signer cette d'elancourt
au micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
alors beaucoup de coeur de la semaine
c'est le dernier film du réalisateur
canadien denis villeneuve et demi avec
une nouvelle fois jack bizlall qu'il
avait déjà fait tourner dans prisoners
qui était son précédent film qui était
lui-même précédé du très bon incendie
donc là on est dans un thriller mais qui
est très différente prise odeurs d'un
thriller plutôt fantastique et
psychologiques qui parle d'une histoire
de sosies mais c'est très prenant c'est
très réussi durée 1h30 et il est projeté
cette semaine sur nos écrans donc en vf
et en vo comme ça vous aurez le choix
voilà le film est aussi interprétée par
l'actrice française mélanie laurent
et qui est ce que c'est terminé pour
cette semaine rendez vous mercredi
prochain bonne soirée à tous